yeah welcome to this video playing f a
19 18 28 a couple of numbers okay the
heck Rafe schlager ohta pflege damn
hunter in German in Dodge um this line
is better than it looks really hmm oh
he's I'm going for the plot sack yeah ok
I'm going to take it not sure if this is
a known line or something I don't mind
to take it so let's secure I was more
concerned about taking a night before
but
and I can even play here and get rid of
the bishop
check
oh I didn't really a can look here I
need to take with the King now the bit
embarrassing Queen takes Knight e5 yeah
okay
ah what thing Ricky 1d seven what what
did i do them hmm poor it's quite hard
to but I can do that actually the Queen
from tech the rook is not threatening to
take yeah check yeah I dont 16
but how to how to regroup him especially
this this Bishop
King c8 maybe maybe get over to be aid
or something
maybe I should have just taken on c4
know that I think of it hmm yeah this
looks like you're the black player here
just had a couple of too many beers yeah
terrible plane but I'm I just just
forgot about this this capture with the
king that I need to take with the king
okay oh this is thought to bed now isn't
it
Gladys should be okay this should be
okay really the king of course still
cause for concern but let's say King b8
the rook is not playing the system this
is of course a problem
Queen B 5 and possibly a five is one way
to go
I cannot take this this gives him an
excellent night this is better i think
getting is night away or if he takes I
control d 60 rattling yeah this is
another way or actually give up the
exchange make sure that yeah come make
sure that I always have a coverage of e5
and King oops King to d7 not removed
please yeah King King can go to the
seven an e5 using the rook
yeah maybe houki one rookie one rookie
too yeah that's good beef could be the
big problem okay but i can i can just
cover check ok form
I could I should have really considered
the check also okay should I just take
on
night-night f4 it's also interesting
the idea is that if he moves the rook I
was just saying the Queen ah what the
heck no Wow unnecessary asst that ah
crazy yeah from a completely winning
palak resins are coming right here okay
before I played bouquet for this is just
a winning hand as just saw it too late
this winds here this attack is too much
it's minus five but I saw this too late
and then he managed the smooth and still
I can i can check check also and then I
then it can take you six yeah okay this
is not so great yeah but blundering the
Queen ER this doesn't happen to me that
often
yeah this is this is a possible line and
completely crazy given by the comp check
check yeah I don't know the computer
actually gives black black the edges HTM
and more time but okay I have after the
rook check I need to check here and
simply win it and not do we do this this
other crap especially not blundering the
Queen ok one is chess just hear this
this is just over over and out one point
is the the check and then King g3 so if
there's nothing moves let's say like
this check there are also this check
check just a mating attack yeah but if
you give away the Queen you rather often
lose so thanks for watching